la france s'inquiète de la situation en
roumanie notre ambassadeur a été rappelé
à paris pour consultation le quai
d'orsay est préoccupée par la situation
des droits de l'homme dans ce pays est à
l'origine de cette inquiétude une lettre
qu'un certain nombre de personnalités
roumaines aurait écrite au président de
chaussée secoue une lettre dans laquelle
les signataires font part d'une d'un
certain nombre de griefs contre lui et
qui est souvent appelé même dans son
pays le dictateur rouge alors si des
signataires auraient été arrêtées jérôme
bonnet pourquoi faut-il urbanisées les
campagnes si dans les villes on ne peut
pas assurer des conditions normales de
vie cette critique acerbe du régime de
nicolae ceaucescu et signé par six
anciens dirigeants du parti
dans une lettre ouverte adressée aux
conducteurs roumains tous les six
viennent d'être placés sous surveillance
étroite de la police par un quasi
réflexe conditionné du pouvoir
leur lettre ouverte dénonce en priorité
la politique mise en oeuvre ces
dernières années pour regrouper les
villages et des racines et des
populations dans des régions de
transylvanie où les paysans sont en
majorité d'origine hongroise ou
allemandes suspect donc pour un régime
qui prône la romanisation les
destructions de petits villages tout
comme les gigantesques travaux de
reconstruction du centre de bucarest ont
pour effet de déstabiliser de façon
permanente des populations urbaines ou
rurales qui ont toutes les raisons de se
révolter
le gouvernement roumain expliquent la
pénurie par les efforts déployés pour
rembourser la dette extérieure du pays
notamment en exportant des produits
agricoles c'est ce qui provoque la
colère de simone veil députés centristes
au parlement européen que toute
importation de produits roumain est de
produire 2 notamment de produits
agricoles ne soit plus accepter pour
l'instant car on sait que si le peuple
roumain n'a rien à manger
c'est parce qu'on exporte tous les
produits
nous ne pouvons pas manger le pain des
roumains la communauté européenne vient
de suspendre ses relations commerciales
avec la roumaine d'une dictature l'autre
la roumanie maintenant c'est le mauvais
exemple des démocraties populaires tout
change pas elle il y à quelques minutes
le dictateur ceausescu
le danube de la pensée comme il se fait
appeler a reconnu que l'armée était bien
intervenu à timisoara mais pour lui ce
n'était que des hooligans ce qui avait
semé la violence
en fait la répression face aux
manifestants a été d'une violence inouïe
hier on parlait de 300 à 400 morts selon
certaines sources fournies aujourd'hui
par l' agence de presse adn le bilan
serait plutôt de 3000 ou 4000 morts et
ce soir on a appris que de nouvelles
manifestations avaient lieu à timisoara
cinquante mille personnes selon
certaines sources manifesterez jérôme
boni dernier témoignage
d'abord décrit habache a hoché ce coup
puis à l'adresse des soldats crise
approche
honte à vous cochons ils viennent vers
nous clame quelqu'un éclate alors les
premiers coups de feu la fusillade
s'amplifie mitrailleuses lourdes
et enfin les chars sur ce document
sonore l'ampleur de la répression contre
les manifestants de timisoara le 17
décembre
ce soir à la télévision roumaine nicolas
ceausescu l'a d'ailleurs reconnu les
unités militaires ont été obligés de
défendre l'ordre et les institutions dit
il les événements de timisoara sont très
graves
il faut maintenant rechercher les
auteurs de ces troubles il s'agit de
hooligans de terroristes fascistes
manipulés par des services secrets
étrangers précise monsieur ceausescu la
capitale budapest est quadrillée par la
police et l'armée
la plupart des grandes villes du pays en
état de siège mais la télévision
roumaine garde le silence sur ces
événements et diffuse ce reportage le
voyage de ceausescu à téhéran le
dictateur marxiste léniniste et athée
s'inclinant sur la tombe du musulman
khomeiny au même moment toujours à
timisoara
de nouvelles manifestations dégénèrent
et tourne à l'affrontement
alors que l'on apprend que tous les
étudiants de la ville aurait été déporté
en roumanie on préfère donner dans le
surréalisme quand ceausescu par exemple
justifie à la télévision la répression
féroce du week-end dernier
ou quand ceausescu ce matin condamne
l'intervention militaire américaine au
panama
la situation semble beaucoup moins
assurée pour le génie des carpates comme
il se fait appeler ce matin en effet de
nouvelles manifestations auraient eu
lieu à timisoara
malgré les wikis les victimes du
week-end dernier par ailleurs certaines
sources font maintenant état d'un
ralliement de certaines unités de
l'armée aux manifestants
patricia cost l'état d'urgence dans
l'ouest de la roumanie a été décrété
hier soir à nicolas et ses fruits chez
secoue les forces armées les troupes de
police ainsi que la milice sont passés
en état d' alerte
le décret pris par celui qu'on appelle
fans du quator prohibe également tout
déplacement ou rassemblements de plus de
cinq personnes et août chez secoué
décidé à se battre jusqu'au bout
ce matin lors d'un rassemblement à
budapest il a donné le taux je souhaite
une action ferme contre les agissements
qui tentent de détruire l'indépendance
et le socialisme en roumanie
le mot à retenir et l'indépendance du
pays
c'est contre la menace qu'ils
viendraient de hongrie
petit engin tout contre pouvoir encore
mobilisés il poursuit organisés dans
toutes les entreprises partout des
troupes pour assurer l'ordre pour
défendre le socialisme pour défendre
tout ce à quoi nous tenons
l'indépendance du pays
nous agissons au service du peuple au
service du socialisme mais on vient
d'apprendre que lors de cette
manifestation officielle des
manifestants criaient des slogans contre
chercher ce qui le discours radio
télévisé a été interrompu au bout de 3
minutes et des manifestants ont ensuite
défilé dans les rues de budapest en
criant à bas qui inquiète school ce
témoignage provient d'un diplomate qui
envoie qui l'anonymat ces diplomates a
ajouté avoir entendu une forte explosion
il y à une heure à budapest
ce soir donc le numéro un roumain
monsieur nicolas ceausescu ne maîtrise
plus tout les situations dans son pays
d'ailleurs le discours du dictateur
comme on vous l'a dit tout à l'heure a
été interrompu à plusieurs reprises par
des manifestants dans la matinée le
problème de la roumanie finalement c'est
moins de sortir du communisme que de se
débarrasser du mégalomanie la dirige
avec sa famille car vous ne le savez
peut-être pas mais en roumanie ceausescu
premier porte le charmant surnom ne vous
tenez regardez bien de fils plus aimé du
peuple génie des carpates danube de la
pensée firmament de l'humanité toutes
ces choses toutes simples
on commençait donc dans une cordonnerie
car ça a été son premier métier son
portrait gilles bornstein 16 ans de
pouvoir absolu pour deux tristes records
fer de la roumanie le pays le plus
pauvre d'europe s'adjuger le titre de
tirant le plus unanimement décrié le
petit cordonnier commence une carrière
de discrètes apparatchiks jusqu au
politburo quand il succède à john joue
day en mars 65 c'est presque un inconnu
un animal de courte durée ceausescu se
distingue d'abord par sa politique
étrangère dif
entre de celle de gurs et des autres
pays du pacte première entorse aux
contrats 67
la roumanie est la seule à ne pas rompre
avec israël après la guerre des six
jours
mais surtout 68 g ou chez secours refuse
d'envoyer ses soldats mater le printemps
de prague
enfin au plus fort du conflit sino
soviétique
bucarest respectera longtemps une
stricte neutralité entre ses deux grands
frères relative indépendance extérieur
donc vitry main pour chaouch et secouer
destination de l'étranger rideau de
fumée pour les roumains qui en
connaissent le prix une dictature
intérieur quasiment sans égal dans le
monde c'est le culte de la personnalité
qui est en roumanie chante la gloire de
chaouchi c'qui le danube de la pensée
qui décuple parfois la lumière pour que
lève les pavots c'est le népotisme
chercher secours est bâti un clan son
clan à l'intérieur de la nomenklatura au
pouvoir sa femme elena et numéro deux du
régime
sa fille son fils son frère et ses deux
beaux frères font partie de l'équipe
dirigeante
c'est enfin la répression un roumain sur
10 appartient à la police politique ou
mesure mieux le courage des quelques
dissidents tel deuil mais un corner
dépression économique avec les émeutes
de la faim à brasov en 86 le peuple
réclame du pain ceausescu lui envoie des
canons répression nationaliste en
transylvanie pour les deux millions de
roumains d'origine hongroise
chaouch et secoue les a privés de tous
leurs droits à raser huit mille villages
et fermer la frontière avec la hongrie
voisine
aujourd'hui toutes les frontières sont
fermées le rideau de fer existe bel et
bien à l'est mais entre la roumanie et
ses voisins plus délirant encore la
destruction du centre historique de
bucarest à la place des ruelles et des
églises chaouchi secoué riche sa propre
ville de béton pour que l'histoire de la
roumanie ne commence qu'avec lui
dernière parodie qui ferait sourire si
c'était au cinéma le 14e congrès du
parti communiste le mois dernier 6e
réélection pour le conte du quator comme
les cinq autres elle suffit-elle unis
la même unanimité présente aujourd'hui
dans les rues pour demander son départ
[Musique]
je
oh
[Musique]
et
hu
c'est pas
et
[Musique]
oh
là monsieur bonjour vous venez
d'entendre le chant du drapeau c'est un
chant qu'on n'avait plus entendu en
roumanie depuis 24 ans depuis que
nicolae ceausescu avait pris en 1965 le
pouvoir alors ce journal spécial cette
édition spéciale parce que c'est fini
parce que nicolae ceausescu n'est plus à
l'heure qu'il est le dictateur roumain
dans une formidable accélération de
l'histoire
il a été renversé ce matin les dernières
informations le dom même en fuite avec
sa femme ils auraient pris un
hélicoptère du toit de son palais pour
gagner l'aéroport et pour prendre un
avion donc monsieur et madame ceausescu
le numéro un et numéro deux du régime
il serait en route actuellement pour
pékin la chine est le seul pays qui
avaient approuvé la répression du
week-end dernier à timisoara
tout s'est brusquement accélérée hier
soir ni les tanks ni les fusils de la
garde prétorienne de chaouchi secours
n'ont pu calmer les manifestants qui
étaient des milliers dans les rues ce
matin et qui ont pris d'assaut et la
télévision roumaine
il y à un peu plus d'une heure c'est le
poète dissident dinescu qui a annoncé à
la radio
ceausescu à quitter le pouvoir nous
avons gagné et bien sûr les télégrammes
continuent de tomber à l'instant on
apprend que les frontières de la
roumanie ont été ouvertes c'est la radio
roumaine qui l'annoncé qui se
considèrent désormais la radio roumaine
comme la radio libre dernières
informations c'est l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères monsieur manescu 73
ans qui dirige avec un front de salut de
la patrie le pouvoir c'était l'un des
leaders de la dissidence il était
assigné à résidence depuis avril
voici maintenant les premières images
d'un peuple à l'assaut de sa liberté
après 24 ans de dictature chaouchi
secours jean-marc il ose regarder bien
ce studio envahie par une foule houleuse
qui vient de hisser le drapeau roumain
devant une caméra
c'est la première image de roumanie à
parvenir en occident contre l'avis d'une
dictature en déroute une poignée de
manifestants roumain vient d'envahir
alors un studio de la télévision
officielle
et puis écouter un cri
mes amis ne dit plus la roumanie
socialiste dit la roumanie au même
moment à bucarest la radio officielle
tombe le poète dissident mircha dinescu
prend le micro et confirme nicolas
ceausescu à quittait le pouvoir
une source diplomatique occidentale
affirme que l'ancien ministre corne du
manège coup 73 ans aurait proclamé avoir
pris le pouvoir à la tête d'un front de
salut national
la confirmation ne tarde pas voici
monsieur corneille ou manier school
images viennent tout juste de nous
parvenir
écoutez regardez il n'est pas du tout
sûr de survivre à son geste de défi aux
autorités
peut-être allez-vous nous vaincre dit il
peut-être allons-nous mourir
peut-être que tout à l'heure ses caméras
diffuseront de nouveau vos discours
cynique mais regardez-moi je ne suis pas
un dieu je suis un simple roumains comme
un jeu vous adjure descendez dans la rue
et venez me rejoindre ici à la
télévision et les roumains répondre à
l'appel et la télévision roumaine parle
et montre premières images de roumains
sans leurs chaînes et de prise de parole
libre libre il faut nous organiser dans
l'ordre et dans le calme dit ce
manifestant anonyme
les hommes de la milice de ceausescu
sont encore par terre et on ne sait pas
où et ceausescu
alors soyons prudents même si un miracle
a peut-être lieu d'autres images
hier seulement tout a commencé à se
précipiter dans cette journée là comme à
son habitude le tyrant bucarest avait
mobilisé 100 mille personnes manu
militari pour dénoncer je cite les
ennemis de l'étranger
incroyable retournement la foule avait
hurlé sa haine
gilles la mélisse et les temps qui
étaient entrés en action à 17h 5000
manifestants étaient toujours là les
forces de sécurité de ceausescu
ouvraient le feu plus de 20 morts disait
les journalistes de l'agencé tass mais
les roumains ne s'est dépeint ce matin à
9 heures il restait toujours quelques
centaines d'étudiants qui résistait les
rafales reprenaient elles ne durerait
pas miracle en dépit de ceausescu
l'armée et non pas la milice fraterniser
par endroits avec la population c'était
le début de la fille après 24 ans de
dictature d'un homme de sa famille et
d'un parti ceauscescu est tombée une
foule en liesse parce qu'un dictateur
nicolae ceausescu a été arrêté après
s'être enfui parce que en se soulevant
le peuple roumain a mis fin en quelques
heures
à 24 ans de terreur et de souffrance la
fin du régime ceausescu en roumanie
c'est un événement historique que nous
vous faisons vivre depuis ce matin et
c'est pourquoi les programmes d'antenne
2 ont été modifiées aussitôt après ce
journal
vous pourrez suivre un magazine animé
par daniel bilalian sur les événements
en roumanie images reportages
témoignages sur l'un des événements
majeurs de cette fin de siècle ceausescu
est donc arrêtée mais tout n'est pas
réglé en roumanie
l'insurrection populaire n'a pas encore
vaincu en effet des éléments toujours
fidèles au dictateur résiste à bucarest
mais aussi dans d'autres villes
alors la situation est elle en train de
basculer
philippe le feu
l'histoire à nouveau la danse et images
que nous venons juste de recevoir d'une
libération en marche
voici la première preuve par l'image que
l'armée s'est bien rallier avec ces
manifestants par dizaines sur un tank
dans la principale artère du bucarest la
roumanie la roma guéris ils sont des
centaines de milliers ce matin alors que
les étudiants avaient appelé à
manifester et qu'ils ont été relayés
dans la journée par les ouvriers en
grève et l'ensemble de la population
il crie ne détruisons pas les preuves du
crime
autrement dit nabli ment pas ce qu'a
fait ceausescu il faut que ces preuves
témoigne pour l'histoire nous sommes ici
au centre de bucarest sur la place de la
république devant l'ancien palais royal
devenu siège du parti
les manifestants ont investi le palais
et il jette par le balcon
les oeuvres complètes de ceausescu
[Applaudissements]
et la foule ils sont des centaines de
milliers reprend dehors le tyran à bas
les tyrans
c'est à ce moment que l'on vient
d'apprendre que chaouchi scouts a tenté
de fuir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et l'on voit les premières traces de ce
peuple libéré dans ces drapeaux dont le
centre a été trouée dont le centre a été
déchiré à coups de ciseaux avant il y
avait au milieu de ce drapeau un épi de
blé un puits de pétrole et le génie des
carpates
ici on barre la photo d'elena elena
c'est la femme de charlesbourg et on
crie au crime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et
[Applaudissements]
compris à la liberté on dit ceausescu
sera jugé mais pour l'instant à 20h
heure française
rien n'est réglé la radio et la
télévision roumaine font état à l'heure
actuelle au centre de bucarest de
bataille féroce certains témoins
affirment avoir vu plusieurs centaines
de morts une fois de plus la télévision
a joué un rôle capital dans cette page
d'histoire aujourd'hui en direct pendant
plusieurs heures des millions de
roumains ont assisté aux discussions de
l'état major du soulèvement
c'était dans les studios de la
télévision roumaine à bucarest
récit de cette révolution direct jean
marc et loose tout d'abord un studio
étriqué une atmosphère de réunions
syndicales
une petite foule qui se bousculent
maladroitement autour d'un micro et d'un
drap
et pourtant c'est de ce studio de la
télévision roumaine que jailliront après
quarante deux ans de communisme
les premiers mots et les premières
images de liberté écoutez ne dit que la
roumanie socialiste dit la roumanie dans
les rues de bucarest les roumains n'en
croient pas leurs oreilles
la radio officielle vient de tomber et
c'est par la voix de mme hirsch et à
dinescu poète et surtout opposant
célèbre qu'ils apprennent que nicolae
ceausescu le tir ont détesté vient de
quitter le pouvoir
déjà une source diplomatique occidentale
affirme que l'ancien ministre déchu
cornelio manescu 63 ans aurait pris le
pouvoir à la tête d'un front de salut
national
confusion sur les écrans de télévision
occidentales le visage de cet homme
acteur célèbre de la télévision
officielle roumaine passera un instant
pour celui du nouveau numéro un
l'information est fausse mais l'émotion
est juste l'acteur n'est alors même pas
sûr de survivre à son geste de défi aux
autorités
peut être allez vous nous vaincre dit il
peut-être allons-nous mourir
peut-être que tout à l'heure c'est même
caméra diffusant
de nouveaux discours cynique mais
regardez-moi je ne suis ni dieu ni
diable
je suis un simple roumains je vous êtes
jure de me rejoindre ici à la télévision
bénévoles et on dépit des vingt morts de
la nuit et des mitrailleuses de la
milice qui claque encore dans bucarest
des milliers de roumains répondent à son
appel
samir images de citoyens anonymes de
roumains sans leurs chaînes et de prise
de parole libre
soyons vigilants attention les hommes de
la milice sont encore partout ceausescu
a plus d'un tour dans son sac
soyons prudents nous ne savons pas
toujours où il est mais le miracle est
déjà là dans les milliers de voix qui
n'ont pas oublié le vieillissement
national roumain
[Musique]
à
et
rien n'est vraiment réglé mais tout le
monde sait déjà que grâce à une partie
de l'armée favorables aux manifestants
les terribles miliciens de la securitate
et eau pour l'instant céder le terrain
dans le centre de la capitale et on
chante
malgré les rumeurs d'une contre attaque
des partisans de l'ancien dictateur en
direction des locaux de la télévision
qui continue à parler au pays et au
monde et avec la nuit la liberté
naissante tombe en direct à la
télévision roumaine incroyable au siège
de l'ex comité central dans l'ancien
palais royal ils sont des centaines de
milliers à écouter les proclamations du
nouveau comité de sages et national avec
s'adresser à la foule le premier orateur
n'utilise pas le terme tovaritch
camarades mes phrases si l'or
mes frères et s'est immédiatement le
délire
[Applaudissements]
puis sa porte et puis sans transition
arrive au balcon un petit homme qui
annonce qu'il est sorti de prison voilà
une heure à peine c'est dimitri matsilo
diplomate roumain des nations unies
incarcéré pour avoir osé rédiger un vrai
rapport sur les droits de l'homme en
roumanie
il avait disparu depuis tous les
orateurs il va appeler à la prudence au
calme dire non à la vengeance oui à la
modération à la télévision le défilé des
dernières victimes connues de 25 ans de
police politique continue dehors
l'histoire sanglante de la roumanie est
encore en marche
elle n'a fait pour l'instant qu'un trou
dans le drapeau roumain un drapeau ou
les symboles du pouvoir communiste ont
été systématiquement arraché nicolae
ceausescu et sa femme elena ont donc été
arrêtés par l'armée à 70 km au
nord-ouest de bucarest
dès ce matin il avait fui en hélicoptère
puis se sentant pour chasser il avait
changé de moyens de transport il avait
tenté de s'enfuir en voiture cette fois
voici cette course pathétique d'un
dictateur en fuite à travers son pays
corinne pertuis ce coût a fui en
hélicoptère de bucarest
ils tentent de partir pour la chine le
comité de salut national qui vient de
prendre le pouvoir
'l'annonce à la foule dans un meeting
improvisé la traque du dictateur va
durer une partie de la journée les
dépêches d'agencé donneront des
informations contradictoires
12h45 nicolae ceausescu et sa femme
d'école du palais présidentiel puis se
pose à l'aéroport de titou aussitôt de
hauts responsables militaires donne
l'ordre à l'armée de se saisir de
l'ancien dictateur sur le point d'être
attrapé il échappe
c'est alors en voiture que le couple
présidentiel et plusieurs de ses
collaborateurs tentent de fuir 14h30
enfin la radio annonce l'arrestation de
nicolas ceausescu et de sa femme attire
goût vise t c'est à dire à environ 70 km
au nord-ouest de bucarest
à peine 40 minutes après une dépêche
annonce l'arrestation denis coux
ceausescu leur fils assis bout la ville
dont il était le chef
nous allons essayer de rester le plus
prudent possible la seule chose que nous
faisons c'est le témoigner avec le
direct avec les images etienne leenhardt
daniel wolfromm le scénario de ces
dernières heures
[__] reste place de l'université 1h14
du matin l'armée tirent sur la foule qui
manifestent il y a des morts et des
blessés ce sont les toutes premières
images d'affrontements roumanie reçu
depuis une semaine
9h30 de la sp annonce que pour la
deuxième fois en 24 heures la foule
converge vers le centre ville
malgré la répression 9h59 lagence
soviétique tu as décrit des scènes de
fraternisation entre des soldats et les
manifestants
les gens ont découpé le sigle du parti
communiste roumain imprimer depuis 40
ans au centre du drapeau national 11
heures les premières rumeurs sur une
fuite de chaouchi ce coup ci recule
devant l'immeuble de la télévision
on annonce le suicide du ministre de la
défense va s'il est niché à 11 ans 29
s'est confirmé l'armée se retire la
place de la république et tout le centre
de bucarest sont noires de monde
[Applaudissements]
11h43 les studios de la télévision
roumaine sont envahis dans le même temps
on annonce la création d'un front du
salut de la patrie dirigé par un groupe
d'intellectuels d'artistes et d'ouvriers
ordre est alors donnée d'arrêter chaouch
et secoue sa femme et son fils ils sont
en fuite
12h58 un bulletin de la fp annonce que
les frontières de la roumanie sont
ouvertes
les premiers journalistes étrangers
bloqués depuis une semaine peuvent enfin
rentrer dans le pays dont 15 début de
l'après midi à bucarest l'euphorie gagne
tout le peuple romain juchés sur les
chars la foule est en liesse dans le
centre de la capitale
[Applaudissements]
depuis la terrasse où hier encore
nicolae ceausescu s'adressait à la foule
en tentant vainement de lui vanter les
mérites du communisme les manifestants
jettent par terre maintenant les
symboles de la dictature
[Applaudissements]
pendant ce temps à la télévision
roumaine que nous avons retransmise et
traduite toute la journée sur l'a5 et en
direct les responsables de la télévision
montrent les victimes de la répression
de ces derniers jours par la dea et
toujours mobilisés en fin d'après-midi
avec insistance les responsables du
soulèvement précise que rien n'est fini
et que des troupes fidèles à ceausescu
peuvent toujours menacé le retour
fragile à la démocratie là monsieur
bonsoir
au soir du troisième jour de la révolte
du peuple roumain contre l'ex dictateur
ceausescu la télévision annoncer la
victoire mais les combats se poursuivent
encore entre la population et l'armée
ralliée au gouvernement de salut
national d'un côté et les forces
spéciales qui dépendaient directement du
dictateur
ces hommes n'ont plus rien à espérer
aucune retraite possible ils ont même
tout à craindre d'une population
terrorisée pendant vingt-quatre années
de dictature
c'est pourquoi ils continuent à se
battre à bucarest et dans plusieurs
villes roumaines retranchés dans des
immeubles ou embusqués sur des toits ils
font régner la peur et continue de tuer
empêchant la population de savourer une
libération qui de toute façon ne sera
plus remise en question jean-marc il use
eric péron demandait rien à personne
c'était un gamin de 10 ans ils ont tué
non assassinés pas tout ce qu'ils ont
un témoignage parmi des dizaines
d'autres sur les actes de violence
gratuite des partisans de ceausescu
les partisans aux abois mais qui aura
entendu hier soir la douleur d'un
adolescent à sybille bastion de l'un des
fils du dictateur déchu sibiu tout à la
joie de sa première victoire sur les
forces de la sécurité
presque au même moment à l'autre bout du
pays gâchis 400 km au nord-est de
bucarest vivait ses derniers combats au
bord de la victoire de peut-être
retrouver
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire en vidéo ci à l'aéroport de
bucarest enjeu stratégique majeur où les
pertes en hommes sont déjà énormes
premières images de reddition mais
l'aéroport est fermé
les forces de la securitate et n'ont
peut-être pas dit leur dernier mot
m
ouais
à bucarest même les symboles d'un
pouvoir commis tombent l'un après l'eau
ici le siège du comité central du parti
communiste roumain seul détenteur du
pouvoir pendant quarante deux ans au
troisième jour des combats la population
toujours aux côtés de l'armée pour
répondre au feu sournois et terriblement
précis des miliciens surentraînés de
ceausescu
aujourd'hui à bucarest europe on meurt
et on crie l'armée avec nous et la
méfiance est partout ici l'arrestation
d'un civil regardez il est du ministère
de l'intérieur
oui mais c'était seulement un type qui
travaillait à la cantine méfiance guerre
du renseignement
ici un commissariat improvisé pour le
tri des suspects l'inspecteur-chef non
il ment à la télévision porte-parole
clés du nouveau pouvoir les émetteurs
sont encore intactes un commando a été
neutralisée de juste à ce matin
le studio de l'état joue dessous est
transformé en infirmerie et on a même
trouvé ici le coeur de se détendre un
peu en musique
[Musique]
ce que l'on appelle aujourd'hui les
terroristes n'ont pas entendu l'appel au
cessez le feu lancé cet après-midi par
le comité de salut national ces
miliciens qui formaient l'armé
personnelle pour étendirent de chaouch
et ce coût se bat non seulement pour
tenter de sauver leur peau mais ils
veulent encore semer la terreur nous
avons tous encore en mémoire le charnier
de timisoara la ville d'où est partie la
révolte roumaine il continue en s'en
prenant à tout ce qui bouge tirent sur
la foule mitraille dans les immeubles et
même sur les hôpitaux
le reportage qui va suivre leproux on
touche là au comble de l'horreur hervé
brusini au coeur de bucarest
la monstruosité tant bien que mal ses
miliciens protège cet hôpital de secours
car dehors on leur tire dessus
on est même venu massacrait jusque dans
ce bâtiment venez regarder dit le
médecin
là
lui c'est un terroriste il hommes en
blanc certainement la securitate et la
garde prétorienne de ceausescu
certains d'entre eux disent les témoins
étaient drogués prêts à assassiner tout
ce qui bouge
m
il y a là une centaine de corps où se
mêlent tueur et victimes des combats de
rue
certains ont été tuées au sein même de
l'hôpital
[Musique]
ça fait plus de 20 ans je suis médecin
légiste même à l'époque du tremblement
de terre j'ai pas vu ça j'ai jamais vu
une telle boucherie gym va tu en as tu
es on a fusillé même ici à l'hôpital
ils ont tiré de ce côté et de ce côté
aussi l'hôpital
je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer une telle
chose j'aurais jamais cru que des êtres
humains soient capables d'une telle
chose
jamais ce soir c'est noël dit
journaliste ya pas longtemps je savais
encore un poème qui disait je te prie
toi bon et juste seigneur sauve mon pays
et mon peuple pour la roumanie libre à
bucarest les combats entre armée forces
de sécurité ont fait plus de 5000 morts
aujourd'hui les médecins roumains manque
de tout plasma sans calment anesthésique
seringue
[Musique]
mais m
à l'extérieur un homme des forces
patriotiques montent la garde devant des
cercueils
devant l'horreur après les combats il
faut nous intéresser maintenant au sort
de la famille chaouche escou cet
après-midi la fille de nicolas elena
ceausescu zoé a été arrêté non loin de
budapest toute la famille est donc
arrêtez maintenant le fils nick ou la
fille zoé que vous voyez sur ces images
si je ne me trompe pas l'image que je
découvre en même temps que vous oui la
voici donc dans cette anorak zoé
ceausescu
arrêtez donc cet après-midi confirmation
par ces images que vous voyez en ce
moment même
quant au couple ceausescu que sont ils
devenus où sont-ils exactement la
télévision roumaine a officiellement
annoncé leur arrestation
hier soir c'était hier soir mais ils
n'ont pas toujours été pour leur part
filmer ou photographier la dernière
version en date qu'il faut toujours
prendre au conditionnel donc affirment
qu'ils sont incarcérés sur une base
militaire au terme d'une fuite commencé
à partir d'un bunker de bucarest où il
avait d'abord trouvé refuge thierry
camelbeeck le dernier discours jeudi
après-midi le commencement de la fin du
conte du catr le début de la fuite
conspué par la foule le génie des
carpates se réfugie dans le palais
présidentiel et vendredi matin jugeant
la situation désespérée il décide de
s'échapper
d'abord vers l'immeuble du comité
central qui jouxte le palais un seul
moyen suivre un des nombreux souterrain
secret qui truffent les bâtiments sur le
toit un hélicoptère latent qui décollent
vers une destination inconnue
à ce moment tout le monde pense que le
dictateur va rejoindre un avion pour
s'envoler vers la chine
en fait à l'extérieur de la ville une
voiture dacia rouge l'attend direction
tir gaulliste et à 75 km de la capitale
là depuis une base militaire secrète il
tente de réorganiser sa terrible
securitate
mais voilà vendredi soir ou samedi matin
selon les sources
il sera arrêté avec une grande partie de
sa famille dès vendredi une dépêche
datée de 16h30 précisé que ces housses
et ce coup venait d'être aperçu un
hélicoptère puis dans une dacia rouge
immatriculée 02 04
nouvelle démentie quelques minutes après
en fait une rue des insurgés pour
empêcher une tentative de libération par
la securitate
voici la version la plus récente de la
fuite du dictateur mais tant que la
télévision roumaine ne le montrera pas
capturer le doute subsistera réception
avec des tables richement garnis de
produits introuvables dans les magasins
de bucarest robe du soir dans des tissus
que les ménagères roumaine ne peuvent
même pas imaginer petit à petit les
roumains découvre le luxe dans lequel
vivait le couple ceausescu et ses
proches alors que la population était
rationné à 100 g de viande par mois et à
6h de chauffage par jour grâce à la
télévision est un album de photos
trouvées dans le palais présidentiel
les habitants de bucarest revoil nagore
un ancien parc de promenade que le
dictateur s'était attribué il ya une
quinzaine d'années et qui l'avait
transformé en lieu de vacances pour lui
et sa famille
port privé bateau château terrain de
sport tout y était construit pour le
bien-être de l'ex numéro un roumain jeu
d'échecs et tire au fusil électronique
pour celui qui se faisait appeler le
stratège des stratèges rencontres avec
des scientifiques pour celles qui se
prenait pour un savant de renommée
mondiale
les roumains découvre ces images du
passé le commentaire ironique et amer du
présentateur de la télévision roumaine
souligne que les nouvelles conditions de
vie d'elena et nicolas ceausescu seront
maintenant beaucoup moins luxueuses un
premier bilan fait état en tout cas de
5000 victimes dans les combats de ces
dernières 48 heures pour bucarest
seulement s'il est vrai que les
terroristes comme on les appelle
aujourd'hui n'ont plus aucune chance de
renverser le cours de l'histoire
il continue donc de faire régner la peur
on vient de le voir à l'instant et en
voici la confirmation avec le reportage
d'une rue wayez spéciaux françoise joly
et roger mode pour accéder à la
télévision qui est le quartier général
est le centre nerveux de la révolution
il n'avait que quelques centaines de
mètres à parcourir mais dans quelles
conditions
bucarest il y à quelques heures à peine
nous amène quelques mètres
un bâtiment dans lequel il est
extrêmement difficile de pénétrer
extrêmement difficile d'approché parce
que toujours sous le feu nourri de la
politique et de la milice alors en
espérant une accalmie qui peut être
viendra c'est dans les bouches de métro
à l'abri qu'on attend le moment du
passage
mais voilà
les concours dans notre entrée de ce
métro l'armée a déjà pris position
depuis plus de 24 heures au bord de
l'épuisement premiers instants de répit
le but est là bas au bout de l'avenue le
bâtiment de la télévision et puis tout à
coup sans vraiment comprendre pourquoi
c'est le moment il faut sortir et courir
rester groupés dépêchez vous
de chaque bâtiment de cette avenue
peuvent partir des rafales d'armes
automatiques des francs tireurs
ici chaque fenêtre est un péril chaque
passant un suspect arrivé sur la place
de la télévision moment de tous les
dangers
l'identification est ici une question de
survie
[Musique]
je travaillais pas
il ya quelques heures encore des tirs
d'armes automatiques partait de cette
fenêtre
plus que quelques mètres les en se
disant que même à l'intérieur des
bâtiments de la télé d'où l'on doit
absolument envoyer ces images des
miliciens sont infiltrés ce n'étaient
que 100 m dans les rues de bucarest 100
m les avec le coeur à 160
bonsoir la nouvelle nous est parvenue il
ya 20 minutes à peine sur nos
téléscripteurs et nos ordinateurs je
vous lis le texte de cette dépêche
le dictateur roumain nicolae ceausescu
et sa femme elena ont été exécutés lundi
au terme d'un procès secrets pour des
crimes particulièrement graves contre la
roumanie
c'était radio milliards est qu'il
annonce c'est donc l'information
principale de ce soir à propos de la
roumanie
très précisément la télévision roumaine
a annoncé la nouvelle tout à l'heure en
direct à des millions de roumains
voici comment cela s'est passé écouter
cet extrait de la télévision tout de
suite nous écoutons cet extrait de la
télévision
dans un instant tout de suite dans une
minute mème pas dans quelques secondes
nous allons voir cet extrait de la
télévision c'était il y a simplement 20
minutes et nous avons le temps de
recaler nos images voici comment le
speaker annonce et puis elle est nature
rocheuse coup au poste condamnable la
morte et je convie ce carré avec
sentenza à ramasse définitive
j'ai un poste exécuta françoise par
ailleurs il me semble que vous nous avez
déjà prend pas un premier reportage
d'actualité concernant cette fois-ci la
composition du nouveau gouvernement
roumain un gouvernement qui sera donc
dirigé par ion iliescu c'est cela c'est
cela je vous propose tout de suite
un document exceptionnel l'interview en
français du premier gouvernement de
roumanie il s'explique sur l'exécution
de nicolae ceausescu et il était
constitué seulement depuis trois heures
quand patricia cost france brice et et
jean michel noël ils ont rencontré en
exclusivité pour antenne 2 au centre
john iliescu anciens ministres proches
de gorbatchev président du conseil
aujourd'hui c'est lui qui a décidé en
accord avec le général militaro
d'éliminer ceausescu en chandail gris le
premier ministre la nouvelle génération
d'ingénieurs
est-ce que vous ne croyez pas qu'en
supprimant le dictateur supprimant
monsieur de chez ocz et ce coup vous
vous privez de là près du principal
témoin du principal responsable de tout
ce qui vous est arrivé de tout ce qui
vous a oppressé depuis 25 ans et que
jamais vous ne pourrez établir les
réelles responsabilités aujourd'hui mais
c'est pas avant de décider à nous sommes
des personnes qui sont élevés d'une
processus très spontané et alors ils
avaient des mange un rat autres qui nous
a pressés de faire
premièrement sur la pression des groupes
terroristes qui voudraient les libérer
nous avons assumé notre responsabilité
commune du conseil
mais nous avons utilisé avec dans tous
les détails
la légalité existantes la légalité de
chercher ce tour c'est à dire nous avons
instruit un processus dans lequel
lui-même il devait se soumettre parce
que c'était un tribunal militaire
organisée d'après certains présument
donc certaines normes qui ont été
respectées et inclut des assesseurs
populaire les g du temps durs du régime
de monsieur ceausescu d'eau qu'est ce
que c'est le dernier acte de la
dictature ou est ce que c'est la
première faute de la démocratie c'est
pas une faute de la démocratie ou
peut-être 6 et peut-être c'est une faute
mais ça ne pouvons pas le dire
maintenant je répète nous étions dans
des circonstances qui ne nous
permettaient nous le pensons le pensent
aujourd'hui encore plus qu'hier qui ne
nous permettait de attendre encore une
situation d'instabilité
il y avait avait plus que ça il y avait
des pressions nous avions nous avons
nous avons des informations concernant
des d'éventuelles attaques sur le lieu
où il se trouvait
c'est ce qu'on peut le savoir il faut
savoir vous ne pouvez pas imaginer je
crois et je crois que personne ne peut
imaginer l'étendue le disons le
l'exceptionnelle qualité de l'appareil
de l'appareil de répression des
chercheurs y aura tidiane sy et scoop et
rayman va deux noms que nous serons
amenés à prénom c'est souvent ce sont
eux les hommes forts ce sont les
symboles de la roumanie nouvelle dès
aujourd'hui ils ont pris toute une série
de décisions
parmi celles ci et il n'y a plus
d'obligation en roumanie de s'appeler
camarades
là aussi c'est tout un symbole encore
une perte une abrogation de la loi
instituant la façon de s'adresser aux
citoyens de la république socialiste
roumaine sous entendu le mot de
camarades et abolit les salaires seront
assurés à la fin de chaque mois
la sécurité est rattachée à la tutelle
militaire ce sont trois des 25 décret
pris par le nouveau gouvernement en
place à bucarest est annoncé à la
télévision cet après midi au pouvoir à
bucarest aujourd'hui le front de salut
national
un comité qui s'est constituée dans la
clandestinité jeudi dernier dès la fuite
des époux ceausescu et qui a réellement
pris le pouvoir ce matin après
l'annnonce de l'exécution du dictateur
parmi eux trois groupes de personnalités
des dissidents des militaires mais
surtout beaucoup d'apparatchiks tombé en
disgrâce sous ceausescu
c'est le cas dionne il est ce qu'on le
nouveau président du conseil
un ancien haut fonctionnaire du parti
pratiquement inconnu en dehors de la
roumanie mais qui dès le premier jour à
la faveur de la confusion a pris de
l'importance
peut-être parce qu'il est le plus
politique de tous anciens membres du
comité central
il est ami de michael gorbatchev avec
lequel il a fait ses études à moscou à
s'écouter le nouveau premier ministre
petre et romane un scientifique de
carrière al'allure jeunes et
décontractée qui parle français il a
fait ses études en france
il n'a jusqu'à présent occupé aucune
fonction officielle
n'était pas non plus un dissident à
l'évidence ce nouveau gouvernement issu
du chaos n'est qu'un gouvernement
transitoire le peuple déjà un conteste
la légitimité
mesdames messieurs bonsoir l'image du
couple cherchait ce coup exécuté a battu
par un peloton militaire c'est cette
image que les roumains attendait depuis
l'annoncé hier de sa condamnation à mort
par un tribunal militaire mais en ce
moment dans un véritable psychodrame
s'ils n'ont pu dire la télévision
roumaine en direct nous allons voir des
images tout de suite le procès ce fameux
procès de chercher ce coup que l'on
attendait depuis quelques jours je vous
propose de le voir tout de suite en
direct sur l'antenne traduit
immédiatement par notre traducteur andry
pornic donc ceausescu et sa femme
viennent d'être accusés ils ont refusé
de répondre sauf devant la grande
assemblée nationale ne reconnaissent pas
le nouveau pouvoir
il ya un avocat qui est en train de dire
que que tout homme a droit à la justice
et que c'est au président de décider au
président du pays qui qui en ce moment
donc n'existe pas
ils ont refusé de répondre à toutes les
questions et ils se sont opposés
évidemment en défenseur de la classe
ouvrière mais ne reconnaissant que les
élus du peuple donc l'assemblée
nationale qui vient d'être dissoute
la dette est en train d'assister sur le
fait que tout les sens doivent être
accomplis respecter les dix inculpés
commettre une erreur s'agit pas d'une
reconnaissance
je suis venu le défendre mais ils
maintiennent leur position
pour l'instant on est visiblement à la
plaidoirie de l'avocat vous l'avez vu
beaucoup d'image arrêté comme nous
disons notre jargon cela signifie que le
procès a été monté comme on dit beaucoup
d'image arrêté sans doute pour ne pas
montrer les membres du tribunal qui ont
condamné et fait exécuter chercher ce
que je propose maintenant comme ce
procès la diffusion du mois a commencé
il ya une vingtaine de minutes de
prendre tout de suite connaissance de
premières paroles de ce procès avec
elisabeth qu'il est devant le tribunal
militaire des torchons l'unique caméra
filme les deux inculpés nicolae et elena
ceausescu jamais leurs juges
l'homme qui fait office de procureur les
accuse de graves crimes
tapez 2 incompatibles avec la dignité
humaine et demande leur condamnation à
mort à cet acte d'accusation todesco dit
qu'il refuse de répondre ailleurs que
devant l'assemblée nationale c'est un
leitmotiv on lui demande qui est
responsable de la situation désastreuse
du pays qui a donné l'ordre tirer à
timisoara qui a fait tirer sur la foule
place du palais à bucarest sur des
innocents ou qui a payé les mercenaires
étrangers qui se bat contre les roumains
et nicolae ceausescu répond répète je ne
répondrai à aucune question sauf devant
l'assemblée nationale et les
représentants de la classe ouvrière
que le monde montante dit il devant ce
coup d'état je ne répondrai pas mattel
mat indienne humaine
[Musique]
ouais
robin
[Musique]
les bacs
c'est ridicule
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]